[Music]
andrew is with us andrew's in atlanta hi
andrew what's up
hi dave pleasure to speak with you sure
um
15 months ago i entered into a
three-year car lease
since then i've learned how foolish that
was and i'm considering how to get out
of it
given the current market and car's value
should i find a way out or
you know specifically would the
dealership let somebody come back in and
just say i want out you guys can make
more on it right now um
or should i just take the lesson learned
and never lease again when it's over
well the way the numbers work out is
this what you're on the hook for
is 20 more months approximately of your
car payment
plus the er plus the closed in buyout
at the end there's a stated value in
your in your fleece that you can buy the
car for
at the end of the 36 months and there's
approximately 20 months of that
left right 30 30 000 plus about
uh it's 800 car payment so uh
it's a monster it's about 46 000 yen
nice car ridiculous big car
yeah okay um and
um so those are the two numbers you can
add those two numbers together
and say that's what the whole picture
looks like now if you wanted to get out
the way to measure against it is really
to measure the 800
per month for 30 months or for uh i'm
sorry there's 20
months left so um is that 16 000 is that
right no it's
160 14 600 14 600 or something
around there yeah yeah am i dropping a
zero
uh but anyway the uh uh so
compare what you have exposure that you
have yeah it'd be 14 000
uh 16 000 somewhere in there um
versus what you would lose on it if you
sold it today
now the way you would calculate that is
you find out what you can sell it for in
this ridiculous
wonderful hot market for used cars and
you compare that to
another number and that's calling the
fleece who have you got the fleece with
you call toyota and say i want the early
buyout number which is the equivalent of
your payoff today
that's not the 30 000 at the end that's
today if i write a check today and pay
the thing off
that compared to the value how far
upside down
are you less i'm sorry that could be
less than
what the less than 15 000.
and so you know uh what was the original
msrp on the car the sticker price
uh i was looking at the lease here the
uh adjusted capital cost is 55. i don't
i don't know what the sticker price was
again i learned the hardware that's okay
all right and uh have you looked up what
it's worth at all
um the trade-in value is around 43 uh
private parties around 46.
okay so let's call it 45 for discussion
purposes
and now you call toyota up and they say
um your early buyout is uh
40. okay you can write a check today for
40 and be clear
then that means you're five in the hole
if you keep it you're 15 in the hole
even
if you turn it in right yeah so if you
want out of it this is probably going to
be a good one to get out of
you're probably going to find you're not
much in the hole right now what what is
what kind of toy it must be a truck
yeah it's a the tundra yeah it's a beast
so what i did going through the
specifics would i find someone that
is willing to buy it from me and then
yeah you would sell the car to someone
and write a check
for the difference in that and the early
buyout and you've got to send that
whole amount to toyota then they send
you a title
okay so i just let toyota know i'm
selling it and i'm
you i'm sorry i hadn't looked up any
details i'm just curious about how that
yeah
well i mean the way you left it's just
like pretend you had a car loan
uh god forbid with bank of america the
title would not be held at your local
branch it'd be held out of town
yeah and so if you did the same thing
and you were upside down there you have
to give the whole amount of the payoff
which is the amount you put with it plus
what the buyer gives you right so the
buyer drives off with a car and a bill
of sale
and the keys that's the way it always
works then you send the full payoff
to bank of america in this case toyota
they send you the title you sign it over
to your buyer
it takes about five weeks okay
four weeks three weeks depending on how
efficient toyota
is uh to get you know to get the full
transaction done
now and if you do it with a dealer
you're going to get less for it because
the dealer is going to buy it at
wholesale
but you're not going to have to screw
with anything they're going to take care
of everything so i'd get a dealer bid on
it
see what a toyota dealer will give you
i'd compare that to what private sale is
saying on
kelly blue book and then i'd get your
early buyout number
from toyota but you're going to write a
check for something here
it's just not going to be as much as if
you keep it
understood thank you hey thanks for the
call man i appreciate you joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
the car fleece is the
most expensive way to operate an
automobile
it is not cheaper
it's more
because when you add up the numbers he
just said
and here's the thing the car goes in his
his example he
msrp sticker was 55 at the time he turns
it back in three years later
the turn in value is 30 thousand he can
buy the car for thirty thousand at that
time or hand them the keys
right now i'll guarantee you this
toyota's a lot of things but stupid's
not on the list
one hundred percent of the time that
thirty
000 has been very carefully calculated
with toyota tundra statistical evidence
that says that that's about what that
car is going to be worth
he's it's not a 35 000 car and he can
buy it for 30 at the end of the lease
and it's not a 40 000 car that he can
buy for 30 at the end of the lease
and it's not a 28 000 car that he can
buy for 30th and lease it's a 30
000 car you could buy for 30. so when
you put that number in there with 800
and something dollars a month you figure
out what his
cost of capital is which is the
effective interest rate
and it generally is around 14.2 percent
it's the most expensive way to buy a
stinking car
don't do it it's a car fleece
you're getting fleeced it's a bad
idea